okay so i've always said like i really
wanted to be able to do a giveaway where
i can give something to everyone like
everyone can win
but the logistics of shipping like a
physical thing to four million people
is a bit of a nightmare obviously but i
think what we have here is about as
close as i can get right now to the next
best thing so this is a collaboration
between oneplus themselves and dbrand
inc so oneplus for the smartphones you
see here in front of you and dbrand for
the shipping and winter verification
this
is a giveaway of 100 oneplus 3t so
here's the specifics i have 100 phones
here uh not just phone boxes but every
single one of these has a 128 gigabyte
gunmetal oneplus 3t inside of it and
half of the phones are skinned half of
the phones are naked so 25 of the skin
phones will be carbon fiber 25 of them
will be matte black
and the last 50 will be just pure
unopened naked so all you have to do to
enter to win one of these is to follow
on twitter that's it so the three
accounts to follow are me mkbhd oneplus
and dbrandskins and that's it you're
fully completely entered also not only
is that the requirement to enter but
i'll be keeping you guys up to date on
twitter should anything change during
the giveaway hopefully there will be
none but i can almost guarantee you that
some people are going to reach out with
fake accounts pretending to be me saying
hey you won the giveaway we just need a
little bit of your credit card
information for shipping no there's well
shipping is free we don't do that so
don't let anyone trick you if there's no
check mark next to the name it's not
actually coming from me but obviously
you can follow on twitter for the most
up-to-date information and also check
the description below so that's it good
luck uh shout out again thanks to dbrand
for handling not only the skins but for
the international shipping so you can
live anywhere on planet earth as long as
you have an address you can win and
shout out to oneplus for being one of
the only companies daring enough to be a
part of something like this and to help
out and to give away 100 free phones so
thanks to both of those guys and thanks
to you if you've been here for a while
if you've seen the videos before if
you're subscribed it's you guys that i
thank to have the ability to do anything
like this and the rest of the videos
that i make so thank you for subscribing
thank you for being on board all four
million of you are incredibly important
to the feedback that i get from you and
all that it's just something that i've
been really happy to do and hopefully
we'll continue to do so thanks
good luck
talk to you guys the next one
peace
you